[Music]
okay you're now live
right hello to everybody and welcome to
another virtual meeting of the trafford
pandemic overview and scrutiny committee
can i just remind everyone this meeting
is being broadcast
live and will be available after the
meeting
via the council youtube channel
can members and officers please remember
use the raise hand
feature if you want to ask questions or
speak
and mute your microphone when you are
not speaking
tonight we have three main items
a report has been provided by each of
the
items for and
the executive member or officer or
representatives
in attendance will give a short
introduction to items before
taking questions from the committee so
hopefully
they will be short presentations because
and then introductions to the report
because we have had the
reports for a while now and hopefully
everybody's had chance to
read them so we go on onto the agenda
proper
the first item is attendance um
and i've i've received apologies from
councillor anstey councillor dylan
councillor new councillor aidan williams
and i think that's it unless he's got
any other uh
apologies no
declarations of interest uh if if you've
got a
declaration of interest in any of the
matters before us
uh please can you declare those i
declare that
i'm a trustee of tdas and
um obviously a school governor of two
schools in trafford
right and i declare that i work
part-time for one of their response
hopes st
john's center okay thank you
okay then we'll move on to item four
question from the public a question has
been received from a trafford resident
who asked and i will read this out
because
the person isn't in attendance
so it is given it has
clearly been established and
[Applause]
yeah so sorry given it has clearly been
established that
not all longford ward residents receive
notification of road closures
on cromwell and norwood and hillingdon
road
uh the up the opposition being
so high and the delays for emergency
services to attend
with there being an increased number of
accidents
two on kenwood and one on norwood
that's three in the space of two weeks
what more will it take before these
planters are removed it is having an
adverse effect
on some residents mental health and
well-being
in these already troubled times
so um i think this came in
yesterday or but anyway we've got a
a response and i'll have to read it out
on me
my phone um
so the council response is from richard
rowe who's the corporate director of
plate
and councillor alzheimer who had said
who is the executive member responsible
for these matters
um and their answer is
the intention has always been to install
the planters
on a temporary basis to carefully
monitor the impact
and at the end of the year once the
changes have
had a chance to bed in and following a
further consultation
consider alternative locations or remove
the planters where appropriate
however having listened to feedback have
received so far your ward councillors
in consultation with the executive
member responsible
have agreed that their planters should
remain in their current position
and in order to gain as many views as
possible from across affected areas
that the follow-up resident consultation
should be brought forward as such
residents will receive
a letter before the end of november
seeking
views on the way forward in addition
trafford counters that sorry
traffic counters will be reinstalled
in the same locations as before in order
to assess
the impact on the traffic flows across
the area
we recognize the strength of feeling in
response to the planters and understand
there are differing opinions on this
matter
as is often the case when road layouts
layouts are
changed however the planters will be
removed
if there is insufficient
public support for them or an
alternative solution
is found that gains widespread support
we hope
the further consultation reassures you
that the community
is being listened to so that is the
response there will be further
consultation
and then depending on that consultation
a further discussion will be made okay
so we'll move on now to item five
which is an urgent business which i
don't have any and
item six is impact of cobit
19 on schools in shepherd and for this
item we have in attendance
councillor heinz who is the executive
member for children
services jill mcgregor who is the
corporate director
for children's services and karen
samples who is a director
of education standards quality and
performance
um it's it's karina carter
in attendance as well i don't know yes
i'm here dave
right yes it wasn't down on me listen i
thought you might be yeah
um okay so um
we've got the report before us um who's
going to
just do a short introduction
um would you like me to do that
counselor hines
um and sorry i was just taking myself
off
off mute there and wasn't sure if i'd
successfully done that um yeah i i'll
just
i'll i will just do a really quick
intro um thanks very much um and
thank you chair for inviting us to the
meeting
um i know we've been asked a number of
questions really
um which we we wanted to answer
um and to bring an update because this
is something that obviously
is you know incredibly important and
it's something that
is in the forefront of people's minds um
and we have just heard from karen there
um and i would like to thank karen
really for
uh preparing this report um and
for all the work that karen and the team
are doing to support schools
and extend that sanctuary to the schools
themselves um who you know are
continuing to face
incredibly significant challenges and
they're doing the best really to
to rise to those challenges in in what
continue to be
you know very very difficult
circumstances
um as you say chair i won't go really
through the report in too much detail
because members
will have read it but just to pull out
um a couple
of uh highlights from the report so i
think
um the the report does detail uh the
attendance of
of children at trafford schools which
i think is very very high um
you know particularly in these
circumstances
um and is higher than the
um the the greater manchester average it
compares
very favorably really to um to schools
across
the region um and i think that is in
no small part you know due to to the
work that the schools have
have been doing really to support
children and to stay
in school um the numbers of
uh children who have an ehcp um
and the number of children with a social
worker
um who are attending school is is
slightly
lower um than the the
average for uh traffic children albeit
that it is actually higher for
um than another gm um
areas um but clearly this is an area
that you know we do want to support and
to try really
um as as best we can to support those
children to remain in school wherever
they
can do so that that um disadvantage
really doesn't
um you know that doesn't get bigger um
so i think the put the report does
highlight
and some of the challenges that the
schools are facing
and and when you look at the the number
of children who've been affected and
impacted by
covet and the figures really speak for
themselves with
um over 9 000 children having
you know needed to isolate at some point
um
over the pandemic which i think has
obviously posed
some challenges um karen and the team
have been working incredibly hard to
support schools
and you know really and and around the
challenges that they face in closing
bubbles
and and also in trying to keep those
bubbles
open and i would also
again really very much like to thank the
team
for um the the work they did in
rapidly responding to um
to the free school meals um
issue over the half-term period
in october i know that the team works
around the clock
that weekend and to get a scheme up and
running
which was very very effective and and
one that
um many of our families did
benefit from um and
just finally really the support and
engagement with schools
uh continues and is very very important
we need to
to continue to work together really
um and i know the education team and
public health
have been in you know very very regular
contacts with schools on a weekly or
fortnightly basis really to provide
briefings um and question and answer
sessions um which i think the
schools have said that they've really
appreciated so that's
very positive and it's something that
obviously we're keen
to continue really there was a question
on uh mental
health but i think uh the question was
asking around
mental health referrals and whether
they've been impacted by the second
lockdown um but i think the data it
might be just a bit lagging behind
really forced to be
able to get a full picture on that
because obviously we're still in that
second
lockdown period now so um so
so yeah i'm happy to answer any
questions
sharon obviously we have karen karina
and jill
so to support with any questions thank
you
all right i've got two people who wish
to ask the question uh
counselor denise weston and councillor
linda blackburn
yeah denise yeah sorry right
thanks dave um thank you for that
report um i was very concerned and as
expected there's been a huge increase
in the amount of cams referrals and i
my concern is that how are we
is the system robust enough to deal with
the
such an increased volume and i fear that
quarter three
will see a further increase obviously
having been in another lockdown
situation
and just wondered if um i could have
some reassurances there please
thanks denise and i know it's an area
that obviously um
the the scrutiny committee have been um
you know really
focused on over the course of the
pandemic
um and in terms of responding
to that currently you able to um
to respond at all for in terms of
capacity
that we know of within cams
yeah i mean um obviously i can't speak
on behalf of cams in terms of what the
current picture looks like
currently um councillor weston um what
what we do know is though um certainly
they've been involved in in sort of
surge planning
in looking at um developing capacity
within the system to to meet the
potential for an increase
in referrals what we what we are trying
to do actually is
is do a wider piece of work around
mental well-being
so that we it doesn't automatically um
result in
a referral into cams um there's been a
well-being in education grant which i
think we talked about potentially at the
last um
scrutiny um we've actually scoped up
quite an
effective piece of work now based on
some of the training that's been offered
where we're trying to build capacity in
the system for schools and other
partners
to meet the emotional well-being needs
of pupils
and before we get to that point in cams
there's a suite of materials that have
been provided on behalf of the dfe
but what we're going to do is make that
available to schools but we've done
a questionnaire out to schools to say
what is the need what are you feeling at
the moment where are the needs of the
students and the young people at the
moment
and our eps and our other
partners in health are going to be
offering bespoke training
and to schools to meet those specific
needs that they're coming across
now as the children and young people
have been back in school for a longer
piece of time
we're also looking at um covid-based
anxiety support as well
we're very aware of a number of young
people who are not able to access school
because of of anxiety
um and and some of that is directly
linked to covid
and so there's a working group looking
at that now where we've actually got
a piece of data we're beginning to
collect more and more data to say what
the numbers are looking like
um the reasons for children or young
people who don't want to return to
school
and again what mechanisms we can put
into place to support that
so there's a piece of work again that
the educational psychologists are
carrying out links in with manchester
university
that is looking at emotionally based
school non-attendance
um so there's some streams of work going
on there and
again that's working with the sector
with our partners
and to look at trauma-based practice
looking at how we can build in
connections with families and young
people
looking at making sure the environment
and the offer is robust
to get those young people and children
back into school
but what i can do if it's helpful
counselor western i can take the
request back to our
commissioners and health services to get
a better picture of how cams
is feeling in terms of capacity and
resilience in the system if that would
be helpful
may i ask um just another
question please i'm quite um
surprised really the percentage of
referrals made by schools
to cams is actually as low as seven
percent
are most of the referrals coming either
sort of self referrals or via parents
and gps or
yeah it it could it could well be um
absolutely um there may be i would
imagine that that's where
um perhaps the parents are kind of
feeling the anxieties of the
of the young people whilst they're at
home and are reaching out to try and get
that level of support
it might be that actually very often
it's like a um
many cases with children young people
their behaviors and their well-being may
not be manifested
um in in their time during whilst
they're at school it's actually been
managed quite effectively
and it's only potentially when they're
getting at home or they're being at home
for long periods of time
that um some of those anxieties and
behaviors manifest themselves
um but again we can we can do a you know
better i can ask uh commissioners um
and and health practitioners to do a
bigger piece of work to understand why
that is the case
thank you that would be really helpful
would it be all right if i just come in
on that point and
i think it's a really great point
councillor weston but i think it's also
important to see the referrals to cams
within the context to referrals to other
support services in relation to
emotional well-being
so you will see in the report that um
referrals by
schools to couth are particularly high
so that's obviously a service that's
valued and appreciated by schools and
seen as responsive
and you'll be very much aware that um
cams obviously has a focus
on um more entrenched difficulties so
actually having supports in at a lower
stage is is really
very important as well but as karen's
indicated we can take away a piece of
work
to do a more detailed drill down on the
resilience across the whole system
what i would like to add as well is one
of the things that's happened since the
last time we came to pandemic scrutiny
with colleagues from
our commission services to look at
specifically emotional well-being
we've stood back up and strengthened our
children's commissioning group
arrangements
so we're actually getting a better level
of
scrutiny on our commission services so
the likes of couth the likes of cams
so it probably would be quite timely to
bring back some
some more detailed drill down in that
area if that would be helpful
yeah i i think it i think it would be
really helpful that
um it's obvious obviously a topic that
scrutiny committee is you know
constantly
raising and i think it is an important
issue and it's not just in traffic but
nationally i think it is so important
i've got three others who wish to ask
questions um
and i'll do it in the order that i got
them um
councillor blackburn and councillor
rose thompson and councillor john lamb
so
uh linda yeah uh could i ask please um
the children and young people who are
isolating at home
are they classed as attending school
if they're getting lessons on on a zoom
or
are they classed as absent
um no counselor blackburn um there is a
code specifically for that
so it won't actually show as an absence
figure so there is a specific code
that's been allocated and that's come
from the dfe as to how
to um kind of record that
that attendance uh when they are
self-isolating
there is an expectation when those
children are sent home to self-isolate
that remote learning is provided it's
actually a legal requirement for schools
to do that now
so they have a specific code schools
will apply a specific code
that's related to covid based absence
basically
okay could i just ask as well and if um
a child or a young person um or that the
family
feel stressed about them going back to
school
is and then that this so they're
actually at home
are they classed as attending or
or is it classed as an absentee through
illness wow um
the department it's a really good
question actually and it's one that
schools are wrestling with on a
day-to-day basis and
and that was one reason why we've set up
the task and finish group to look at
covid
based anxiety because it isn't just
about the children feeling anxious it's
parents as well
and it could be because they've been
previously clinically vulnerable or
clinically extremely vulnerable or all
sorts of circumstances
and we're seeing it absolutely in the
north of the borough too that's where
we're seeing a lot of our fears and
anxieties
the dfe have made it very clear that
attendance at school is mandatory
they've made that absolutely clear
so therefore when children and young
people
aren't attending because their parents
are too anxious to send their children
in that's when there is no requirement
to provide online learning
because it's it's a requirement that
children attend and young people attend
however schools are being very sensible
and very um sensitive and understanding
to the needs of
families and their children and the
circumstances within which they are
they're living at the moment so there's
an awful lot of work that's going on
um just they're working individually
with families to really try and even if
it's engaging on a part-time basis even
if it's engaging in
can can would it be okay if the child
just attended for core lessons for
example
and just to try and build up that
confidence i think
uh back into the system to enable those
children young people to attend
so there isn't an automatic route to uh
to
apply a fixed penalty notice or anything
like that we're really trying to be very
sensitive
work with families build back the
confidence and this task and finish
group is looking at sharing good
practice about how we can make that
happen
can i just be clear about the attendance
of the overall
attendance you probably did answer it
but uh
i was probably slow to get it um
at the moment the overall attendance is
92
percent so does that include those
children who are isolated i know that
you you've gone over that but
does that figure include those because
92 percent is
it's clearly less than what would
normally uh
expect um so there's a gap between that
92 and what we normally get and and
they're the ones that we're talking
about
now are we yeah those that are
worried or whatever yeah
yeah that's absolutely right i think
again
just to apply a little bit of caution
around the 92 percent that's dependent
on schools completing the attendance
portal as well and
we've been we've kind of discussed that
before so um
there is an expectation that schools are
at 96 attendance rates that's the
government's expectation
um and that's got what schools are
actively working to
to try to aim for um but yeah so uh
basically from the portal our overall
attendance figure currently
is well that was on the i think it was
the 6th of november that was kind of
when i submitted the report so it's
probably
will have changed by now but it's
sitting around 92
yeah overall yeah thanks for that
um councillor rose
yeah and i just want to say that
85 of ehp students attending school
is really good i know across the country
it's not just greater manchester
but across the country attendance for
all students is 80
so to be up to 85 for those students is
really
to be you know recommended it's really
good my question is about
i believe that the neu reported that
700 000 students are without
laptops or broadband and
able to access remote learning i just
wondered what's
what's happening green traffic for those
kind of students
um i've not got the exact figure of any
students or families that have been
without laptops we'd like to think that
they are very few and far between
because what what we did do and i think
we possibly discussed this at the last
pandemic we tried to have a really clear
strategy about how we just make sure
any vulnerable children and young people
have got access to technology
so we allocated the laptops we made that
available to them from the supply that
we
got sent we did have surplus so we've
managed to we did a push out back out to
schools to say
have we missed anybody do we need to mop
up anywhere so schools have had another
opportunity to apply for the surplus
that was left over
now i think possibly what what has
happened is
the dfe have offered another allocation
to schools
and i think that possibly is where the
neu have kind of reported from and i
know that
um there's been some challenges i think
around schools being able to uh not only
have a fair allocation
but also to actually get hold of those
those digital devices as well
um but we we continue to work with
schools to make sure that wherever we've
got any concerns
we will we will do everything we can to
enable those young people to have access
and that might be through the virtual
school as well for our
children in care so we we've done
everything we can and
we we talk about it i think every heads
meeting it comes up
so that they're certainly not letting us
uh you know fall asleep on that one that
they're making sure that those devices
are available to children and young
people
but i i i'll try to bring any data that
have if that would be helpful to you
uh i'll send that through to the next
meeting yeah i think it would if it
could be included in
the next report that'd be really helpful
yeah absolutely um
we've got john lam and um barry winston
me uh councillor lam okay thank you very
much uh
chair and uh just to welcome this report
it's uh
it's a good concise uh report which
gives us a
a good sort of overview of where we're
up to with
our schools and i just wanted to pick up
also on attendance and
i think rose thompson has drawn
attention to the good
attendance on the part of you know
children with a
health and education plan and i i would
agree uh with that
um but it is an average figure and i
suppose my question was
uh and similarly for you know those
children
uh you know receiving support from a
social worker
if we look at those that might be well
below
that average figure for trafford i know
schools
will have a focus on them i suppose my
question is
you know do do we as well centrally uh
have a focus on
those children who are really a lot
lower than than that
than that average if you like yeah thank
you for that question
again another really great question and
i know jill's
smiling there because this is something
we get challenged on
by the dfe and the regional schools
commissioner on a two-week
basis so we're kind of used to to having
that question uh sort of thrown thrown
at us as well to be fair
but no it's a really really good
question um so we have a variety of
mechanisms in place and i'm sure jill
will probably want to come in on this
too
whereby if schools for example are
concerned about non-attendance
particularly of children with social
workers
um then we have a strategy where
because we've wrapped around a lot of
support around the individual schools
they'll have a name
social worker that they can contact to
refer that absence as well so we can
make sure that somebody's got eyes on
those children and those families
and we can look at whether they're
isolating or what the reason for the
absence is and we can get them back into
school
the same goes certainly for those
children with an ehc
we are aware that out of those uh young
people that have some level of covet
anxiety
um the vast proportion of the returns
we've had from schools are coming from
special schools
so clearly there is still a lot of
anxiety the children and young people
with ehcs
and probably to to do with their really
complex needs
and there are still some concerns and
again we're working with those schools
and with those heads to ensure that we
can we can return those children back
into school on a regular basis
what we do is we have um we have a sip
report as well as sitrep report which
you'll probably have seen
in relation to the covid cases so
again what we're trying to do is ensure
that where covered cases are reported
that the contact numbers are kept as low
as possible because
what we what we challenge the schools
back on is if there's one covered case
and they're sending the whole whole
bubble home is that actually
actually appropriate um because actually
they won't all be contacts
so we're trying to really push back on
schools as well and get them to think
really carefully about who needs to be
at home
and who should be in school and social
care colleagues as well have sight of
those sitrep reports
and also have sight of
attendance data as well and and where we
do see that low attendance
where we've got low numbers of children
known to social care or those with an
ahc
on our portal information we can share
that with colleagues and put the
challenge back to schools as well
so we've got quite a robust data set
that we can analyze
um and use really to question and
and hopefully get some answers on why
they're the the absences is in place
sorry it occurs to me that that might be
uh how we've got a good average of
course
yeah so thank you thank you if i can
just follow in
council council alarm follow up actually
um
as well as all of the things that
karen's described in terms of the
sharing of the information
targeting both settings schools
and pupils where it looks like there's
a reduction in attendance as well as
sharing that
information throughout the whole of the
the pandemic
we have worked on the basis that social
workers need to see
children and they need to have
conversations with children and they
need to have conversations with their
parents and one of the things that we've
said they have to ask
about is why is your child not in school
should they be in school and what does
that mean for their lived experience so
one of the things that
um perversely it might seem that the the
pandemic has really helped with it's
it has definitely helped with
cross-service
conversations and and strengthening some
of the relationships with our schools
from our our social workers
so that we're seeing children's lived
experience in that rounded
context because the majority of our
children do go to school
so for those that aren't going to school
it's really important that we understand
what does that mean
for what's going on for them in their
lives and how we can promote that
so genuinely really delighted with the
collective approach
karen describes it as a pincer approach
that we work
really closely with our schools that we
challenge our schools that we share the
information with social care
social workers and equally we ask our
social workers to love education as much
as karen and her teams do
because that's the pathway to
achievement and aspiration for our
children
okay thanks for that
um we've got councillor barry winston
lee
barry want to ask a question uh yeah i
had two questions
but rose asked my first sorry council
thompson asked my first question
[Music]
i'll ask i'll ask the second question uh
which is
if it could be an increase in home
schooling during the um
during the pandemic and is there any
support within trafford uh for people
who are
have decided to home school yeah
i think um certainly in september we
absolutely saw an increase in
electively home educated uh children
that has actually dropped quite
significantly
so after that initial peak um
we have actually seen it drop and and
certainly the num the number of new
families electing to home educate for
this month in november
has dropped significantly um what i can
do is
um perhaps when you move on i can pull
up the dashboard and put some numbers in
the chat
if that's any help to people what we
what we are doing is always is because
it it it is absolutely the parent's
right to do so
and actually from the information that
we've got on our dashboard
um the actual number of cases that are
as a result of covid are still quite low
i think there are around 19
uh new cases that were actually linked
directly to covid
and the majority of them are for their
own personal reasons there might be
philosophical reasons there could there
could be all sorts of
reasons for a family opting to to
electively home educate
um we are seeing the majority still in
the north of the borough which is
interesting
um so we have quite a clear and detailed
snapshot
of the overall picture um we have
a an officer that's dedicated to ehe
and he will link him with families as
well to offer support
um we we always ask the parents to have
a conversation with the school as well
and just be really clear that this is
the absolutely what you want to do
so again where we can we encourage a
dialogue to happen before the decision
is taken
but i think what is positive in some
respects from our point of view is those
numbers are coming down now
um but equally it is a national issue
it's
you know this is not dissimilar to what
other places across the country are
are finding
thank you can i just finish my one
observation chair that's okay
and it's really and it's really it's
really a shout out to the uh
the officers within um within traffic
who are the agent with schools because
my
i'm i'm many of us are one of the
governors at a
local primary school and my son is at
the
um is a local secondary school and the
teachers
within within those schools are
have a lot of praise for the team within
trafford
particularly when contrasted with the
help they get from central government
um so yeah i'd like to recognize that
contribution i also like to recognize
the contribution of the
dub teachers in of the teachers in
trafford as they go through lockdown and
release and lock down and release i've
never seen just a bunch of frazzled
professionals in my life
but on they go and on and on and uh and
on they carry
so a recognition to the all the teams in
traffic who involved in this
making sure thank you thank you very
much okay
thank you for that barry i think uh we
we would all echo your words in relation
to that i think
uh you know the schools uh all the staff
in the school
so every single member of staffing all
the schools have done a
remarkable job and i think they've been
supported
uh brilliantly by you know our officers
here in
in trafford and uh i think we're very
grateful
for that and the executive members um
and i think um
we finished the questions except for one
which is which is my question
and that is around uh closing the gap
and
recovering lost ground uh which is on
page
four um and it does say that
um in one of the paragraphs that um
that um we're having you know some
success in
in in terms of that with the um
with the um the way that we're actually
dealing with it and tackling with it
tackling it um and i just wonder how how
you
um know that the schools are
uh closing the gap how do you sort of um
you know record that and
and ensure do you have a methodology
in in terms of how they're actually
closing their gap
yeah yeah basically uh what we do is we
all schools have to complete a self-view
now the self-view document which has to
be signed off by the governing body as
well
um what we're asking schools to do is to
show us evidence of how they're using
catch-up funding
how they're prioritizing the curriculum
delivery
what their recovery curriculum looks
like because that is absolutely about
making sure children and young people
are in a good place to learn and to
catch up
so how they're using any additional
funds to to make up that
lost learning um we're also asking
schools to
um share with us the remote learning
policy as well
and when schools feed that back to us
they're doing at the moment the end of
the month is the deadline to do that
that's how we actually categorize our
schools to determine whether we feel
we need to get more information whether
we need to actively challenge a little
bit more
whether we can sign post schools as well
to support each other
and so that becomes our quality
assurance mechanism and for those
schools where we don't feel there's
enough rigor
or or a robust evidence we will do
visits out to the schools
and we'll have the conversation with the
heads and we'll talk about exactly what
they're doing
to in order to address that lost
learning i think
some of the challenges really for our
schools currently is
it's just the the number of pupils that
are isolating
um what we are finding with some of our
schools is because they tend to be
clusters in the same area we know that
stratford is an area where we're seeing
an awful lot of cases on a regular basis
um i think what heads are trying to do
in terms of managing some of the
the issues they are trying to prioritize
and protect year groups
so that they won't be disadvantaged for
example they're trying to protect year
11 so that they're in a good position to
take their exams should they take place
as normal
in the summer and you know they're
trying to do everything that they can to
address
some of the gaps that they know they're
going to be dealing with as well as use
some of the digital devices to encourage
some level of online learning as well
so schools you know they've got the
funding for tutors
they've got the catch-up funding as well
governing bodies should be
quality assuring some of you know some
of that spend as well
but we're asking for that evidence you
know in order for us to be informed and
then
you know add the challenge and the
support where required
thank you for that okay i think uh we've
asked
all the questions um i i
repeat really i think everybody's doing
a fantastic job and
uh we're very grateful for all the work
that
you've done i i actually think that the
the report was you know
a really good report because it wasn't
too long
and i i always judged by how how long it
is
and i think it was straight to the point
and that's easy to read and and that's
always helpful i think for
for members um so we we we're grateful
for that
so thanks very much thank you thank you
you know the officers and
the lead member and executive member
much appreciated as always thank you
right we'll move on now to um
item seven which is a community hubs
um for this item we have in attendance
council harding
who is the executive member for adult
social care diane eaton who is a
corporate director of
adult services joanne gibson head of
all age commissioning and anne-marie
jones chief executive of age uk
trafford um so i don't know who wants to
we've all had the um the report
and again you know it was an easy
read um and
um so who's going to just
uh introduce the report i'll introduce
it chair and then hand over to um
joe and anne marie if they want to
contribute on any
gaps but i leave so to speak and it
would actually be
really nice to hear from anne-marie if
she's okay to maybe give some
a viewpoint as a hub leader really
because um
so i guess to start off with i would
like to say thank you very much to the
pandemic scrutiny committee for inviting
us because
um i think it would be fair to say we're
incredibly proud of the work
of the community response hubs and to
pay tribute to them if we could
um mimic really the tributes um
and to thank all the community hub
leaders and the volunteers that have
been involved
in the work of the hubs really i'm sure
you
all know setting the scene to back in
march
when um the pandemic first hit
and we started to see and the community
wanting to
develop some of the mutual aid networks
and what we then developed as a result
of that and and kind of
built on was that how did we make sure
that those people who wanted to develop
the mutual aid networks
were supported but how did we make sure
that those people
in our communities that were potentially
most vulnerable
were supported by way of a humanitarian
crisis response for things like food
prescriptions and well-being
so um as a counselor of
sort of 10 years constantly battling
bureaucracy
and um barriers and challenges
it was quite remarkable really that a
group of i would say probably about 50
of us sat in a room
back on a monday in march and knocked a
few heads together
decided what we wanted to achieve and
within the space i would say probably
about 10 days we had six community
hubs settled and established certainly
a blueprint for what we wanted to
achieve
and i think again it would be fair to
say that we've just grown
and grown and grown really and the good
thing is that we are
flexible we're responsive we know that
the picture is changing
as we've been through the second
lockdown so the first lockdown was
definitely very much
we were learning and feeling our way
through what we needed to do
we have lots of things to iron out so we
had to make sure that all the governance
processes were in place that things like
safeguarding
and data sharing all of those things but
making sure
that it wasn't a top-down
uh response really we were really clear
here in trafford that what we wanted to
happen
was this was about the voluntary
community and faith sector
as they are they have always been most
responsive in trafford we have a
fantastic partnership network
so it was about making sure that
whatever we did we weren't command and
control that we did it together
and i think joe and hopefully emery will
bear testament to that but i think we
have co-produced
this model and we've learned as we've
gone along we haven't always got it
right but we've definitely co-produced
it and i like to think that all the
partners that are
around the table at our weekly hub
meetings feel that they have their
voices heard
and they are definitely part of what we
will move forward for for the future
so um so the report is pretty
self-explanatory i don't want to
to sort of go through side by side can i
just give thanks to
catherine o'connor and the programme
team as well
because catherine is incredible at some
of the presentations and the graphics
that she she puts out for us and we were
able to then proudly send those
presentations out into the wider world
and the community to showcase
exactly what trafford is doing so thank
you to the programme team for their
support too
so we have these six hubs as you know um
and we had a memorandum memorandum of
understanding between the hubs
about what the offer would be and how we
develop and grow
so we are now in um phase
two of your life of lockdown and we're
now preparing for christmas the hubs are
preparing for christmas and what the
offer will be
we've just had a hub meeting today
you'll know that
the um citizens advice bureau is the
triage line so the o300 number which is
out there
in the public domain is the number which
the public will call first of all
and then people are triaged and referred
out to the hubs
so that the hubs can look to respond to
meet the public's needs
and jonathan yates who's the service
manager today has said that there have
been
600 calls through this last week to the
cab
and then we've had i think 65 calls
passed out to the hubs
so we've seen a fluctuation over weeks
as we
came out of restrictions over the summer
the hubs were still in operation but the
calls
obviously decreased they have now
stepped up again and
joe uh maybe you would give us an update
on the clinically extremely vulnerable
work that we're doing in trafford and
how the hubs are supporting that work
so i think it would be fair to say that
really we just
we are continuing to meet weekly the
hubs are up and about
running providing all the services we've
all of the hubs have now developed a
template um
of what is on offer and we're very happy
to share that with pandemics brutally
but the offer continues to be around
food
and food parcels so we have very close
links with the food banks
a lot of the hubs have a blue sky worker
with them or one of the social
prescribers community connectors
and we are focusing on digital exclusion
that's one of the areas we've identified
that
we do know there's a huge gap in
trafford it's great that we can all join
this call tonight
but there are so many people in trafford
that they're not seeing their family
and they're certainly not able to get
online so there's been some
very specific projects that the hubs
have been involved in to develop
the digital offer and how we get more
people involved
a really great example is the digital
buddies where we've worked very closely
with salford foundation
and the other um piece of work that
we're looking at is
loneliness and social isolation and we
have
um a key group that meets on a friday
morning where we're going to be thinking
about how we really
tackle that issue um so
i'm going to hand over now so i feel
like i've just done like a big
stream of consciousness about the
community hubs there so
i'm very happy to take any questions or
equally joe and anne-marie if you would
like to fill in any of the gaps that i
that i've left there
joanne gibson dear joanne do you want to
yes you would thank you yep and
so it has been an amazing um program of
work to be
involved in and i too were sat in that
room with 50 people
back in march and it's it's absolutely
phenomenal the way
and the pace that that kind of that the
hubs were delivered really but
i think one of the questions for the or
from the pandemic scrutiny committee was
around what the future of the hubs is
as well um and you know we do have
we do want this to be our kind of um
build-up of our understanding of what
place-based working um
is like um and how that then fits into
some of the
strategic design groups which diane
might want to talk about and so
so really there is a future for the hubs
there's a future of this kind of
way of working and we have got a whole
strategic design group called living
well in my community
um of which the hubs is a major part of
that so
for those sub groups of that group as
well it's
it's around place-based working
understanding how we can work in a more
place-based
way and focusing in on those localities
understanding the rich kind of
um range of services and people that are
there to support each other
and it's also about a strong information
and advice
approach as well across trafford and
again
at a kind of a um a local level
and we want to make sure that we've also
understand what the health inequalities
are like across trafford and we've got a
working group that
looks at that and how that can play into
that place-based working side of things
um and
and there's one more and it's it's just
escaped me
there's another work group as well so
all of these
i suppose just wanted to say or just to
reiterate really that
we've learned so much from the pandemic
in terms of community working
and we do want to take that forward and
learn even more and make sure that we
have a really oh that's the other one
the final one was a strong and
voluntary sector so we're doing a lot of
work around how we
you know work differently with the
voluntary sector as we have done in this
situation these
these hubs are not commissioned services
it's all absolutely done on
memorandum of understanding and a whole
group of partners that have come
together to support that
and another really important aspect of
that is um trafford housing
trust and the traffic crisis fund that's
been that's been put in place
in order for um sort of funding to be
made available to the voluntary sector
as well
and um yeah so
i think that's it i'm not happy to take
questions
yeah thanks for all that you do
and anne marie jones who is the chief
executive of
age uk traffic did you want to say a few
words
yeah yeah i can do um i yeah i would
reiterate what joe and
and uh well joe and joe the two joes
said about co-producing it i think one
of the things it gave us an opportunity
to do
as a vcsc um sector was to demonstrate
how responsive we can be
i think we always say that but this
gives us the opportunity to really
uh demonstrate that practically that we
are very responsive and very quick
at doing that and i think we were
ideally placed in our local communities
as well
as six response hubs to do that and
there was an opportunity for voluntary
sector organizations to work together in
ways they haven't done before
and that will continue to develop as we
we develop
the way forward for the hubs and and
also for us to work with
organizations that we might not have
worked with before so
for age uk for example we wouldn't
necessarily work with children's
organizations but now we
we have partnerships with those
organizations and
and the the only other thing i think i
was going to say was that
part of what has developed out of this
is that
most of the hubs are now the lead
partners
for their area in the new
vcse collective that is being developed
as well for the
for the future of the vcsc in trafford
so i think that's been a good
good development too good
good stuff um are there any
questions members want to
to ask um
can i just ask um obviously the
the feedback from the survey that
you know um around the community
you know the user service
survey all of which were
really really positive uh responses
um which is very heartening
i suppose what i'm going to ask really
is
that there are always those people
the most difficult to reach uh category
of people um and i wondered how you've
overcome
that or do you think we still you know
don't pick up people and i'm sure
that will be the case um
and also i just wanted to to to ask
about the domestic violence
[Music]
which was featured in the report and i
just
wanted to know you know how
the hub is helping in terms of that
domestic
value particularly you know
when we have the lockdowns and so on
[Music]
so it's just those points that um i
don't know who wants to answer them
can i answer the one about the hard to
reach um um chair and then i'll maybe
hand over to joe on some of the domestic
abuse um work
if that's okay and or we can both maybe
pick that up
um so i think you're absolutely right to
raise
there are people in our community we
only know what we know don't we
at times and we know people that are
known to us from the clinically
extremely
vulnerable list so that's sent through
to us from
national government or we have lists
from primary care
so we know the people that we know that
we need to support
um but one of the concerns that i've
always had are those people that live
alone that aren't known to services that
tend to slip through the net
so i have a particular area of interest
in people who have substance misuse some
mental health issues
that maybe haven't accessed services and
certainly people with
ongoing physical addictions to alcohol
who is critically important they get
access to alcohol
uh or can become very unwell so so those
that that's one of the areas that i felt
we
needed to have um a spotlight on really
and i've
worked with some of the social care
teams on that the other issue we have is
around language and we have the leaflet
translated into different languages
because we have language and culture
issues too
you know sort of the the ward profile of
ernst
is incredibly different to the ward
profile of old trafford
and we need to be really aware of those
kinds of things
so i think one of the things we've tried
to do this time well not tried we have
done
we've had a leaflet that's gone through
every door in trafford this time
we didn't do that last time and the
survey that went out
highlighted and i certainly know from
the health watch report
that highlighted that a lot of people
just said they
they weren't aware of the community hall
you're going to know about the community
or if you need to use it or if
if you're on a facebook page under
leaflets there or if you're on twitter
or if you're on
the council website it goes back to the
digital exclusion point that i raised
earlier if you're online and you're
connected
you'll know about things but but you
might not if you're if you're not
connected at all
so we still have a way to go as to how
we reach out
into communities and we do need to think
about language and culture
we did do some work with some of the
mosques
um certainly around when we were picking
up the the higher rates in certain areas
we did some outreach work with the
partnerships team we continue to do
outreach work and now that letter has
gone out
and the clinically extremely vulnerable
letter has gone out
we have started to see an increase in
the volume of calls
that are going through to the hubs the
piece of work
that joe mentioned on the health
inequalities and the voluntary and
community sector
we're hoping that those work streams
will help us
identify better how we reach out but i'm
not going to say that we have
an easy fix to that i think we all know
that
it's about developing those partnerships
and
not relying on statutory services
for the council to do everything the
development of the mutual aid groups
have been brilliant actually and
stratford
community hub i think has been um one of
the leaders
in this area so they have street based
maps where they've got neighbors who are
on whatsapp but again if you've not got
a phone and you're not on whatsapp you
wouldn't necessarily
be part of that group so there are
different things
happening at a micro level in the
communities
and the mutual aid conference has helped
us again think about some of the things
we need to develop
we're on a journey with that we've made
incredible progress but we've got a way
to go
and any any way that this committee
or ward councillors can help us achieve
how we reach out into our communities
then we would absolutely welcome that
and the hub meetings meet once a week on
a tuesday
we do have guest speakers anybody that
you think we need to be aware of
please do let me know and we would like
to hear from anybody that can help us
reach people in communities
good stuff that's great i've got
um counselors
john lam and geraldine uh goggins
um john first
all right thanks sir thanks chair um
well again i welc i welcome this uh
report and can i just say i think it's a
great
report as well it says a lot in a uh in
a in
a relatively short sort of space um
i was interested in joe gibson's comment
about
um you know these not being commissioned
services instead
you know being services which are sort
of governed by a memorandum of
understanding and i wondered whether
that was the
clue maybe to uh the success of
the uh the hubs uh and
i suppose the question i'd ask is going
forward if we are to develop
uh these these hubs and capture all that
good
work that um has been done in the
community and
marie was talking about you know the
various connections that have been
made which just sort of organically
happened if you like
um you know and and the quite
sort of hopefully dominant role that the
uh
voluntary sector have taken how to
ensure that we
sort of retain all those good aspects
of this which we know are serving our
communities very well
and do appear to stand a much better
chance of reaching those people that
it is not always easy for public
services to uh to reach
shall i come back and yeah so it's
it's it is interesting isn't it um in in
terms of co-production
what we what we and what we know of
co-production and the sort of definition
of it is about giving up power isn't it
and really being sort of equal footing
around the table so yes actually i do
think that memorandum of understanding
and the fact that that the council
aren't commissioning people to do
specific things
has been um you know has meant there's
been a lot more freedom and a lot more
conversation and a lot more working
together a lot more partnership
really going forward so that's exactly
what we need
to get to understand more and again in
in terms of that um group around a
strong
voluntary sector how we work with the
likes of the collective going forward
how we work with tht how we work with
all of the partners across trafford that
that do have funding to bring into
trafford
it's going to be really really key and i
think that will enable us to
to make sure that everybody can play
their part really going going forward
i think the other thing um within the
slides there was one
slide which one of my favorite ones is
it's about that future community hub
support model and actually one of the
first things that we need to make sure
that happens in trafford
is that everybody is really encouraged
to be really neighborly
because actually we don't want everybody
coming to a support hub
we need to make sure that um people you
know families look after each other
we need to make sure that we have strong
communities so that neighborhoods
and neighbors look after and the people
on their street and so on
and the the mutual aid groups is
fantastic that's kind of the next piece
of the
of the chain but yes they they need to
be helping people as well
our community partners need to be
helping people our community hubs are
there to support people
and ultimately statutory services need
to support people as well
so it's that whole chain um that kind of
rich offer of
of um of help across all of those
different
organizations or people in trafford is
really key about then reaching the hard
to reach
thank you and councillor
coggins thank you thanks for the report
and the update um it is amazing what has
been done in a short period of time
and i was wondering how the pubs are
doing four numbers of volunteers at the
moment there was some concern a while
back i think that we were a bit low on
volunteers and i was just wondering
now that i suppose we're coming to the
end as it appears at this lockdown
how they're how they're doing and and
yeah just to
reiterate um about the digital divide
and isolation there that the two things
i keep um encountering and that i know
the hubs are are really making a
difference on
and chris actually like i think it's
been mentioned
um uh providing an opening for
people who are otherwise difficult to
reach just to actually get in touch and
say they need help and
and if we can get over that digital
divide and
then then those people will be able to
access help more more independently
thanks thanks geraldine i think one of
the things i would say about volunteers
and
i'll hand over to anne marie because
obviously um as one of the hubs you can
you can speak on that but at the
beginning we had
a massive response from the community of
people
signing up to be volunteers it was
amazing really
and thrive as the organization that
supports us with um the third sector
voluntary community sector
were helped along with the partnerships
team in trafford to coordinate
the volunteers and some of those
volunteers
what we wanted to make sure was that
volunteers were dbs checked because it's
about being safe
so even you know sort of delivery
drivers going out
if you're in contact with another
individual so making sure
all those governance structures were in
place and volunteers
we developed actually a really good
comprehensive training package that was
um rolled out from trafford so that
included safeguarding there was training
around domestic abuse
on boundaries and so on so again if we
had a driver going out and they
noticed that there was potentially an
adult at risk score
and knowing the process of how they
would report that to make sure that we
really looked out for people
you're absolutely right in that what's
happened is as has
people have come off furlough or they've
gone back to work then we've seen a
decrease in volunteers
but also not all of the volunteers ended
up assigned to a role because
the demand it fluctuated at times
and then we also there was the nhs
goodsam app which is still
around two so we've got we've got an
awful lot of people
again in traffic i think are signed up
to the nhs goodsam app too
so what we're trying to do at the minute
we do recognize
because christine from old trafford
mentioned today that they don't have as
many volunteers
as they used to have so each hub is now
looking to
recruiting their own volunteers as they
used to do i guess before we we went
into this whole model
and they will follow their own processes
around the dbs and the training
um but also how we're linking with good
sam to look to allocate some of those
roles so for example if the hubs don't
have capacity
how can we link him with an already
established group of volunteers
that could quickly pick some of those
things up
we're also looking at um we've had a
session today
on apps that look how we develop our
data
and linking with other organizations so
we are
kind of steps on we're growing all the
time really
but you're right we don't have the same
volume as volunteers that we used to
have
and i think anne-marie you can probably
answer better as a hub that's live
really and what your volunteer
status is like yeah um i mean it was a
bit of a concern for us going into this
second
lockdown whether we we would have enough
volunteers because
we did use a lot of volunteers who have
been furloughed
in the first um first lockdown and
obviously they'd all gone back to work
and so it was a concern that we might
show the volunteers
however in the in the first lockdown we
were doing a lot more
practical activities if you like so we
were doing a lot more personal shopping
we were doing
um free food deliveries we were doing
the um the
food bank deliveries because the food
banks were closed we were picking up
medication
we're not doing any of that at the
moment so we're not
we don't need those volunteers to that
level our own volunteers as age uk
traffic we're all in the vulnerable
group and still are so even though we've
got
over 100 volunteers very few of them are
actually working for us
at the moment they're still still in
lockdown so we haven't got our own
volunteers to use
but this time around we where we have
needed we've only had a few requests for
shopping
because i think a lot of people in the
first lockdown got everything in place
and in the second lockdown there hasn't
been such a demand for it
and where we've had one or two we've
been able to refer to the nhs responders
and the same for some befriending calls
and for medication pickups
so we haven't had that same demand for
our own volunteers this time around
and i think in with the other hubs they
did retain
some of the volunteers that they they
recruited although
the numbers were smaller but again the
demand hasn't been as high
for those you know very practical
activities more
information provision people wanting to
know what what the new lockdown means
what tier the three tiers mean how it's
going to affect them so it's been more
about that kind of thing really
in the calls and than the actual
practically
delivering food etc this time around so
far
okay there any other
questions no um
yeah can i just um have my thanks
really to to to to all of you here but
uh clearly all the volunteers and uh
other staff who've done a
an absolutely remarkable job
in very very difficult circumstances and
i think it you know
it's something that um everybody should
be proud of
in terms of what they've achieved in
looking after people
um and i think you know
as we move forward hopefully we come
through this pandemic that
all all the sort of measures have been
changed you know the um
[Music]
excellent examples of how community can
work
together continues um
you know in the future really and it is
an interesting point i think that
john lamb raised in terms of
the memorandum memorandum of
understanding um you know instead
probably commissioning
services is something that i think
you know maybe be able to be developed
even
further um how has we
moved forward um but but can i thank you
all tonight for for coming along and
the work's not done yet is it uh because
it's not over it's not over yet
and and it won't be for a little while
yet
so um thank you so much for all the work
that you've done
and it's much appreciated by
so thanks again okay
uh can we now move on to uh item
eight which is a health watch uh
trafford culvert 19 report
[Music]
and uh for this item we have in
attendance uh heather fairfield
who came to our last meeting
and heather is the chair of the health
watch
and she
did send us as she promised
the survey
report uh and i think it was
uh very interesting uh but if
uh heather if you wouldn't mind just uh
an introduction of that record that
would be
very very helpful okay thank you chair
um you'll note from the report that we
sent around that we had 250
responses to our survey but in addition
to that we also
spoke to more than 40 individuals either
professionals
or members of the public there are two
other things that we're doing at the
moment
the next thing and is that youth watch
our youth watch
are going to be putting together a
report which should be out within the
next
uh couple of weeks and we've also on
behalf of
all of the boroughs in greater
manchester
uh compiled the results of their
surveys so in actual fact the the
sum total of all of the districts will
be around
3 000 respondents so i think that that
will give a really um
a clear idea about um how people feel
about it
um if we just look at some of the key
messages really
um the biggest one um is about
communication
because what people felt was that they
needed up-to-date
and accurate um information
and of course they take their
information from a variety of sources
and it's really key that you know those
people providing
uh information provide what is
evidence-based
and um can be relied upon
and i think the um
some of the um biggest things were
really about
people that hadn't accessed services and
although
services are now building up again and
people are going into a
e into hospitals and so on uh they
didn't for quite some time
and i think that a lot of that was to do
with the fact that people
felt that perhaps services were swamped
uh there was some fears about
um you know coveted itself and would be
safe in going in and those sorts of
issues
but as i say i think that um
that is getting uh somewhat better now
and i know that
local hospitals any attendances uh back
up to what they were
uh pre pandemic
um one of the big things and the
asks of the general public is that they
need information really
um on when services are going to
recommence
and that hasn't always been clear and
i've just been on one meeting
where um some services are going to be
closed down for three weeks
and it's very clear that it's a very
movable situation and things change from
one day
to the next next and you know in some
instances it really
can't be helped but i think generally
speaking
and if we're looking at services in a
community particularly
it would be really good to know when
services are being um stood
uh back up uh some of the likes that
people had were um
ask my gp um and some of the online
services
but the um the opposite of that is
that there are lots and lots of people
within trafford and indeed elsewhere who
are not
digitally connected so they really don't
have
access either to broadband or they don't
know
how to use uh digital services
of course uh if people have used
libraries
previously that they've not been able to
do that
so um i think the groups where that's
been particularly an issue has been
around some of the
uh the bain groups the poor uh
the elderly and and in some
places in trafford as well because we
assume that if a newspaper goes out it
goes out
you know the freebies they go out to all
the houses but
they just simply don't i think they stop
at the river mersey apparently
um and don't go beyond that so i know
that even within my own organization
when i've been able to say
something such has happened some of my
directors have said well
i don't know because i we don't get that
newspaper or all that information
um there's been lots of questions about
uh
one one one um i think some of the big
things that people have experienced have
been
the loss of links with family and
friends
loneliness has paid a very large
part in that and of course lots of
people do
live on their own some of the concerns
have been about people with long-term
conditions who have not been able to
access services so
people that require physio or um
psychological help or or whatever
and of course there's been a big impact
on jobs and
people's finances but some of the things
that have been
seen that have been good is that being
with family in many
instances has been good um
some people working from home having
enjoyed working from home they might not
love zoom but they love not having to
sit
in traffic queues and of course
the climate will have improved at no end
especially earlier on
when there were hardly any cars on the
road um and
lots of people are going back to nature
and listening to the birds tweet
in the morning and and and finding all
sorts of things that they never knew
existed
so i think there's been lots and lots of
positives as well as negatives
when i look at the the big um picture
as i said that gm uh we we've put
together the information from there
and that will be published within the
next two or three weeks
um but there's a lot of commonality
with what we in trafford have done as
well in our survey
so clarity around communication was the
big thing
uh not clear about when services will
resume
the impact on mental health and i think
that earlier on in our survey
it didn't appear as though loads and
loads of people have got mental health
problems but of course as time
has gone by uh people
[Music]
and the main issues there again are
isolation
um anxiety panic at panic attacks
and so on and the good things is that
services have adapted digitally but as i
say
lots of people can't access digital
services and and there's been a lot of
engagement with specific groups across
greater manchester
um interpretation um
on information in different languages um
has proved to be important but not
always
necessarily provided but in one or two
areas some of the bain communities have
got much more
support than their white counterparts
which i think is
is really good because people have been
imaginative
about how they've been able to contact
with them and of course there are
voluntary groups an example in
manchester there's some
um chinese community groups there
and they've been able to keep the
chinese community
um in in
well up to date with what's going on and
the other thing that was surprising in
manchester
uh 40 percent of the respondents that
manchester had
were really from uh people who were
disabled
uh as well as uh the chinese community
um so i think it just sort of serves to
illustrate that for each of the boroughs
um there are different issues uh
but communication and being
informed when um services are going to
be
back up and running seem to be the two
the two key themes
so happy to take any uh questions
thanks thanks very much for that heather
uh i think
you know again you know the report was
easy to read
uh and uh very grateful for
for coming to la for coming along to
introduce it and i think
uh council lamb has got a question
i have chair thank you very much and
just to uh
follow from pure comment we seem to be
sort of blessed tonight don't we with
exemplary
reports you know i think this too was a
really good
uh report well set out and again with
some very important messages and i think
that's where my
question really is but before my
question just a an observation one of
the things that struck me uh
which hadn't really occurred to me
beforehand reading the report
was uh those members of our
uh community uh who
have lost confidence uh in terms of you
know going out and facing the world
again
um and i i haven't really sort of
thought about that as being an issue
for us but certainly as a council i
guess
as we get into recovery
then we need to think about you know
those members of
our communities who um are probably
not going to move ahead as fast as most
of us will
in terms of just getting confident again
about going out
and facing facing the world quite
frankly so that's just an observation
a question uh heather was
the future for this report because i
mean as a scrutiny
committee we would uh you know we're in
the business of sort of
you know help trying to help by making
recommendations it strikes me that
there's a good set of
ideas and recommendations here so my
question is more about
um you know where does this report go
very interesting that you're talking
about a consolidated report
across greater manchester which will
probably uh
strengthen some of the uh views that are
expressed here but as has also been
stated these are specific to
uh trafford um so so yeah what you know
where where
where are we hoping this report may go
where on whose death does it need to
land
right well it's already landed on 250
people's individual desks
so that's the starting point and we hope
from there that it will
pan out and that people will discuss it
and i know that um links in the council
and within the ccpg it has been
discussed and i know that
people have taken on board and picked
out some of the
recommendations and thought about um how
they could address those
um and so i'm i'm hoping that you know
uh from little acorns uh uh some
great oaks will um it will grow really
um because i think it does resonate with
really how
a lot of people feel and i think your
point really
uh john about the um social anxiety
i mean i know now a lot of people that
are suffering from social anxiety
and i'm sure that gps will be picking up
people who
um you know they're having to try and
and meet their needs and in duke of
course
i'm sure that some of our mental health
services as well
and we'll have to try and pick up on
some of these issues
and and we also must remember that we've
got a wide
voluntary sector and we have
lots of um organizations
within a voluntary sector that also meet
people's mental health needs as well as
things like
um addressing isolation and so on
are there any other did i just come back
back very briefly because
i think heather you're absolutely right
about you know the mental health and
anxiety uh and maybe i've not quite read
it right but i was also picking up a
thing
that you know there might be a number of
people who
uh are at the easier end of the spectrum
if you like
who just need some support to actually
you know get on a bus and
and face a supermarket again and all i
say because for some they may not
not have done it for such a long time um
so it's just thinking about that whole
sort of range of uh
anxieties that might be there which
don't necessarily require
you know the professional uh sort of
mental health services but just again
you know help
quite literally from a neighbor a
helping hand maybe
yeah and i think that lots of the um
sort of contacts that people have i mean
you've mentioned
things like what's up i mean i've
noticed that in my community
whereas i don't know two or three years
ago i used to think well what is
community i don't even know who my next
door neighbor is
but i think that that has changed and
and people have
reached out and i think there is a lot
more kindness
now um than there ever was before
and so i would hope that the community
hubs would be a good vehicle for being
able
uh to help to improve this and certainly
within healthwatch we have
um lots of volunteers and again they are
they all have their own networks as well
um
and so i think it hopefully it will grow
and that people will get the um
support that um that that they need
yeah are there any other questions
no can i just say that what's the word
cutting can i ask a question
oh judith right yes sorry
first of all um very interesting report
and one of the things that i kind of
picked up on
and certainly with um the
gps and i get a lot of text messages
from from my particular surgery
which i find really helpful and the
dentists also
do this is there any way that can be
extended
and to other services um and
given that some people will not have
um i was going to say phones how
how do the doctors get to those how to
reach people
who don't have the necessary um
um films or things like that although i
know you can leave text messages on the
ordinary films as well
yeah i mean i think it's a really good
question and it's something i'd
perhaps like to ask the gps when i next
speak to them
and whether they send round um
you know leaflets or not i don't know
um i think some of them possibly do and
but it's it's a good question and and
that's why people are isolated and
living on their own
um and why it's such a big issue that
the report's drawn out
because we're not we're thinking digital
all the time
and smartphones and computers but you
know there are
lots and lots of people that just do not
have access to that
and i think that that's one of the
inequalities that we're going to be
faced
with in the future and and how we can
overcome that
yeah yeah i would agree because um
there's a lot of people who cannot
access services or any
other opportunities just because they
haven't got um
the technology um and it's particularly
i think with older
or as you say perhaps poorer people and
we've been discussing about children
having access
to the internet and to to tablet
and to me it seems to me a priority
for those people who aren't actually who
can't access services that way
to actually um to be able to
yeah i mean i think that the financial
situation
um is clearly uh very key in this
with people on fairly people who have
been made redundant
and so on and although we didn't go into
the financial side
um in any significant way in this
particular survey
and all of these have an
impact on that because people are more
worried about how they're going to pay
their
rent their mortgage and put food on the
table and
and that i think in covert has been a
really really
um pressing issue for people
yeah um to know the
questions can i can i just
um sort of comment myself um
when i'm in the report i came to the
same conclusion the exactly the same
conclusions as you did when you
introduced the report that
um the the sort of main
findings is around communication
accurate information um and when
information is sent out
it should be very simple in in in very
simple messages and and that sort of
runs through
the whole of the of the report and i
think it's
it always isn't about communications
and you know most problems it's around
how we communicate with each other
and i did pick up on on the point um
around the hubs who'd sent out material
to you know to the community and
um there wasn't a a reference to
health watch or a phone number um
and and i'm sure that you know
it wasn't meant to be like that but
those are the things that are quite
important aren't they that we get those
links right
we get that communication right
well our website has had seventy five
thousand
um hit in the first um
in about six months which is more than
double what we normally get in a whole
year
so i mean i'm concluding from that that
people have found it uh
useful um and that they found that the
information
reliable so they've kept on coming back
so
we we were delighted uh with those uh
sorts of figures and and we hope it will
continue
um and um there'll be lessons that we
can learn
uh from the feedback that we get from
people
yeah no i i think that's absolutely
right and
and i i think you know
we need to share it as well as we can oh
you're you're
you're sharing it and you know landing
on people's desks and so on which i
think is good uh
because people need to to sort of read
it
um well can i thank you so much heather
and uh
you know and all what you you you do and
healthwatch
does um you know you do a remarkable job
um and it's not easy sometimes we we
we know that and you've been doing it
for a long time as well like me
in terms of being a counselor um so yeah
thank you so much for that it's really
really helpful
thank you okay so um
they're the main items uh so um there is
a couple of uh items
left on the agenda which is basically
uh for the committee members to
to run through really in terms of what
we want to do
um you know for scheduling
other meetings so everybody else can
can leave if they so wish they can stay
if they so
wish uh but can i thank everybody for
coming along
tonight and can the members just remain
um for the last uh two items
okay can i thank you all thank you much
appreciated
all of you thanks and have a good
evening
okay right um
so item nine is to consider the briefing
note um of the chair of the committee
which happens to be me
so i just wonder if you managed just to
see that
what the topics were the the sort of
headings
i think we may wish to add one or two
to that particularly after tonight's
meeting uh
you know around the house and
traffic help watch maybe
so is there any others that
you know you'd like to add to it yeah
judy
[Music]
are you muted judy i have declared an
interest that i'm in
and at the time trustee of tea das but
also you were
asked about domestic abuse which of
course has been on the increase
um during lockdown and given that
they're now sort of talking about spring
rather than
it's ending next week if you like
because it looks just
going in another lockdown and this has
an impact not just on
um the people who are the victims
of domestic abuse but also on the
children
um of the households there as well
and i just wondered whether that's
something that we need to look at
because also the other thing as far as i
understand
um domestic abuse has now become much
more complex issue
um as well it was i knew this
because um i i attended a
volunteer sector organization meeting
that was some time ago
and every organization that was
represented there was saying how complex
that domestic abuse was
but in fact i think it's got even more
complex it's not just
one issue it's it spreads across the
board so it may be something that we'd
want to look at
and the other thing that i would like to
ask
as well one of the things is and we're
having
an impact of coronavirus on school and
children and one area is
well the welsh area has already said
there were going to be no
exams next year and i have a concern
if this is going to carry on which it is
what is the impact of
our children in trafford because that's
what we're concerned about
uh our young people entrusted on their
exams next year
and whether we should be looking at this
or at least lobbying government
to say is it a good idea
and to have those um exams in in the
summer
sorry that's just a couple of um oh
that's a
that's very helpful yeah um
made a note of those and uh
can i just bring in geraldine and then
barry
just briefly um i see on the um on the
note the circulated act of transport is
mentioned there and
when i did raise some questions when we
discussed that i was told that the
answers to those would go to exec
so i just wanted to confirm that they
will go alongside this to exec
uh for this december date sorry the
answer to what geraldine
uh do you remember we raised several
questions
and oh yeah yeah
i got some answers but um what was said
was that they would be sent to exec
and so i just wanted to confirm that
they would maybe go along with this
yeah i don't see any reason why not
yeah okay thank you that would be fine
um barry
uh thank you dave yeah it's it's really
to expand on the mental health services
section uh
i think it's critical to mention cams by
to actually specify
that it's got to cover cams because i
think the uh
well i i suspect the mental health of
every everybody has suffered during cope
with 19 i believe that the tsunami of
mental health amongst
kids particular reference to that
and to reiterate what's uh what judith
that
some clarity in the persistent band is
going to be interested in because if
they're in degrees of lockdown you know
the only the
results of an exam next uh next
september the only thing it's going to
test
to test is how often kids have been
self-isolated from school it's not going
to test anything else
so yeah finish thanks jeff no
so i i don't see a problem with that i
think mental health
will will be featured in in any anyway
through the education part
heading um
are there any other well the mental
health as well one of the things that
you say is refer to camps referred to
reverse
to 42nd street but actually the schools
are doing their own
um mental health supports as well aren't
they
it would just be interesting to hear
what the schools are actually
um doing in relation to mental health
because i have to say the schools are
doing a brilliant job i think
yeah and this crisis
and and we need to say that to to to the
teachers and staff
at our schools and colleges
and but you know it it
they they also have mental health
facilities
in place it's that support that they
they do for the for the children as well
or young people
yeah i mean i think um obviously
we've got to pull it all together and
and
[Music]
the head you know it's just a heading to
this moment in time
and um and what
what i've kind of said is that you know
this should
[Music]
there should be probably
you know short text
really but still think to
to to the point really and that's what
we're going to try and achieve
and what we'll do is send it around
to members because it's easier once some
something's on paper really it's easier
for you to
you know um add to or take away
and because it won't be my report it
will be our report
so is that okay yeah yeah
good um so
we've got penciled in
a meeting for the 15th david sorry can i
just
i did i did raise my hand and i was uh
i'm sorry yeah i don't
know where it's okay uh and it's just to
make the obvious uh
point that having just uh sort of
considered the report from healthwatch
um i think i mean this would be an easy
one in terms of yeah
you want to keep the reports up saint i
think we just need to presumably
sort of uh endorse those recommendations
uh yeah and you know that's a it's a
quick win in a way because they've done
the work
and uh i think we should just get behind
it exactly yeah i've
i've i've put that down so so i think
from tonight's meeting it's a hubs
and health watch and we have talked
about
domestic abuse as well and
judith obviously reiterated that um
so so and and the other point is the
exams children's
um but you know obviously there's a
national
view and uh whether there's local views
and
there's welsh views and and so on in
in terms of that and you might all come
to different conclusions
i mean i i i can't see
how they can sort of have
exams this next next year
um because it's going to be just as bad
as last year
so um anyway
i'll we'll get something together
and we'll send it over to to to you
and then hopefully we can get it done uh
for the end of the year i mean every
chance that we will have the three
other committees next next year rather
than
just the one pandemic but that's not
been decided
at this moment in time
i'm advocating
but that means nothing
no not at the moment david i think
denise wants to come in please
all right sorry denise i'm desperate to
come in and you're ignoring me
i'm not bitter it's because i have to
scroll along
i know scroll roll along i know i'm
trying to talk as well
no i think all those points are really
good um
if we are having the meeting in december
i think i would like an update on the
uh test and trace as well just to see
how that's going i mean the kids have
had more or less a full term now back in
school
i think they're due to break up on about
the 18th anyway
so i think it would be quite do you
think we we i mean first and foremost
we've got to agree whether we want
to to have a meeting uh so so
i we agree that we do have the meeting
on the 15th so
you know it's getting near to christmas
time i don't know it's
up to you i don't know i mean i think
personally um i think we still have a
lot to discuss really in this pandemic
scrutiny
um we've had a what i consider a really
good fit
a session today um and we do need to
keep an eye
on um certain things um
and also particularly if we can make
recommendations to the executive
yeah so i'm happy
yeah and it might be i'm i'm
i can't remember when i discussed it
with
alex and john addison when we want to
get this report
done because it might be an opportunity
to have that discussion at that meeting
but we wanted to try and get it
by the um by christmas really
we want to get the report so that
they've got it
but for the end of the year really
because it's a kind of end of the year
report i think it'd be timely to have
that paul try and pull everything
together
but john
[Music]
um computer at the moment i've got to
ask him to unmute
uh well hopefully i'm just economy
can vaguely
okay uh sorry chair um yes the view was
to get the report to the executive i
think it was the 14th
of december 14th of december
will it'd be too late then one to the
15th yeah
yeah so that scope is that
um i mean we could
but when do you think we'll have it
ready
john
the republic would be ready for the
executive on the 14th
we would hit that we would hit that
deadline if
you wanted to have it to go to the 15th
pandemic scrutiny meeting
the executive is the 25th of january
if my memory serves me in the new year
so there's a little bit of a delay
um and as you said the the three regular
screening committees may be back in
operation by that point
yeah it would be nice to get it
sort of you know if it is our last
meeting maybe we could
come together before
the 14th rather than the 15th
just just to do that really and maybe
one other thing
if if there's a you know an emerging
emerging issue around
you know coming out a lockdown or
whatever
tier we're gonna be in you know we might
want an update
on that
but the main item should be probably the
report
so i was just going to say i can't see
my computer scratched i can only see
yourself as a little tiny window
and i can't see what i'm i'm doing on
screen um
the difficulty with bringing the
pandemic scrutiny committee forward if
that's what i thought you meant yeah i
did before
is quite choker from a governor's
perspective we would be very stressed
that week plus there's a council now on
the 8th
okay well let's let's get the report
done and then we can decide but do we
want
do we still want to have the meeting on
the 15th i think we we can agree
that then now um and hopefully
you know we'll take care of the report
in the best way that we can
uh i know karen did you want to speak
chairman yes i mean although i am keem
for us obviously always to meet when we
can
i just think we need to be sensible
about what we think we're going to
achieve and
obviously taking up officer time just
prior to a really really busy time i
just wonder if it's worth reflecting on
whether
it is actually good use of officer time
just prior to christmas when things are
probably going to get really busy
in terms of kind of practically the
officers working to prepare for the for
the christmas
uh period so i'm always keen to have
meetings but i just don't want to feel
that we ought to have one just because
we ought to have one it we need to be
making a real difference and will we be
by meeting thank you
yeah i mean that's why i'm raising it
if i could just say david i i i think
i'd be in favor of
keeping that date uh in the diary uh
it's
you know post the lifting of the
national lot down
uh presumably we're gonna be in greater
manchester in a
tier three uh lockdown uh there'll be
more information
about the vaccination program that's
going to be running
uh presumably from the new year uh
onwards
um and it may be that we can find
ourselves
to you know an update on those issues in
terms of you know what are the numbers
like in trafford and so
on so uh maybe the key to it is is is
uh you know keep keeping keeping that
date in the diary
but just having an update on obviously
what's going to be quite a different
situation by the time we get to
the middle of december yeah i'm i'm
i'm relaxed either way but i think i
think that's a fair point
um i'm happy to to
to go along with that geraldine
it's just too echo uh pleased to keep
the date
in the diary um we normally have three
scrutiny committees and we're down to
one
we know that councillors are often um
struggling to make the meetings that
they're
they're meant to be at because there's
the change in time
and and then there's absolutely enormous
amounts of change going on
mind-blowing budgetary pressures it
seems like this isn't the time to say
let's have less scrutiny this is the
time to say you know we've really got to
keep our eye on the ball here yeah i'm
happy with that
so i think i think there's a majority to
do that
um karen
[Music]
yeah i mean as i said i'm happy to meet
but i think we have to
make a difference just being a
repository of information we're not
making a difference
we're just receiving information so i
think i think
that's the the thing i was trying to
kind of distinguish between i'm all for
receiving information but
you know that could be put through other
channels and i just think that
we have to be you know maybe it's worth
liaising with the officers just to see
if they've got the capacity
around that 15th of december to um to
meet and
you know for people to provide us with
reports they all take time it's going to
be a really busy period
there'll be lots of contingency plans
being developed so i mean obviously
i'm always keen to me tonight i think i
was the advocate of having more
scrutiny not less when we changed the
pandemic scrutiny
committee but i just want to be sure
that we're really making a difference
that we're not imposing an awful lot of
extra work on people
prior to what's going to be a very very
practically busy time for the council
yeah i think it's always been in the
diary so
it's not um you know
it depends what we put on it i think
that that's the thing and it probably
will be
probably about the you know
what will what we'll be doing then at
that
particular time you know which tier will
we be in or
or you know
it's changing isn't it every day so
sometimes you've got to at least
i suppose give yourself some room to
to keep that meeting in the diary
and if we find that there's nothing to
fill it in
or we yeah we haven't got the capacity
then
that you know we will have to accept
that but
i think no reason why we shouldn't uh
you know have the meeting and uh
and you know put the important stuff
on on the agenda but not to fill it
you know so tightly really okay i think
that's the thing
and bear in mind that it you know it
will be uh
christmas not long after that so um
so i think we we can do it
and i think we can do it sensibly
so so we'll leave it in the diary i'm
you know i'll do some work with
the officers around it and keep you
informed
all right is that okay
right well that's what we're doing now
okay then is there anything else um that
anybody wants to raise
before we go yep
geraldine uh well just the next item was
about
discussion topics for future meetings
which i think we've urged on to in the
last item
and and just to plea and you'll be
surprised can we discuss
active transport again we're due to have
um i think the council may have had
although we haven't had details yet and
the trench to
results um imminently or perhaps they've
already got them
and obviously the um trans one schemes
have been in place for a while
and i just wonder if it is the last
meeting and of this group
is it a good time to have another look
at that question
well we could have we can ask the
question uh
you know prior to the meeting and see
what the answer is
in terms of what what has actually
happened since
we last spoke about so well what's
happened is the branches have gone in
and
by that time we will definitely have had
our trench to result so we'll know
what's happening next
so that's that's why i'm requesting that
we could have a look at it again
okay that's fine
everybody okay with that yeah yeah
um and obviously whatever's happening
at the health front i think
yeah okay right
well that um concludes the meeting
and as always have a safe journey to the
next room